so we'll get back to covid we have the
story from Essence uh from from The
Washington Post I love how we were just
ragging on the Washington Post and now
we're gonna rag on them again
on Saturday Night Live Woody Harrelson
pushes popular covid-19 conspiracy
theory the actor worked in a joke during
his monologue that repeated a pandemic
plot favored by vaccination opponents
notice how she didn't say exactly in the
headline what he said
oh here it is yeah he says um do they
have the quote he says the uh in a
monologue filled with references to his
abiding use of marijuana the actor who
went that's hilarious just right there
because like the left is the has always
historically been like the pro pot and
now they're alive but now they're using
it as a cudgel to beat him with only
because he's not saying here's what he
said he read us he read a script where
the biggest drug cartels in the world
get together to buy up all the media and
all the politicians enforce all the
people in the world to stay locked in
their homes and people can only come out
if they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over I threw the
script away I mean who's gonna believe
that crazy idea being forced to do drugs
I'd do that voluntarily all day long and
so that was his joke and the live
audience offered scattered laughter but
viewers at home had much more visceral
reactions what I love is it's like
there's like a paradox in this article
there being the media is being made fun
of for calling as an anti-vaxx
conspiracy it's like well hold on there
a minute big Pharma literally lobbies
the government that's not a dispute yeah
they go to politicians more than any
other industry yeah they're massive they
made 100 billion dollars they had
guaranteed no liability contracts and
we've all seen the video brought to you
by Pfizer brought to you by Pfizer
brought to you by Pfizer they brought us
everything cool this year they're buying
ads like crazy they buy ads like crazy
they sell products they Lobby
politicians Woody Harrelson wasn't
saying any kind of conspiracy theory no
he was making a joke about every joke
has its truth big big pharmaceutical
corporations lobbied government and the
media to try and convince people to take
their drugs it's a product they got no
liability contracts made a lot of money
off it now they're calling Woody
Harrelson a conspiracy theorist but I'm
not here to talk about the negative and
I don't want to I don't want to sit here
and and and and just rag on me like we
always do I Want To Praise Woody
Harrelson and say hey look man people
are pushing back this is a mainstream
celebrity hosting SNL talking about we
should not let massive multinational
corporations dictate what we can or
can't do that seemed to be the message
right
so we're good all right
Victory yes I just think it's funny that
they're like you're a conspiracy
theorist like if you weren't if this
wasn't a direct comparison to what
you're doing you wouldn't be so
threatened by it like if you weren't
doing something Shifty don't freak out
right I I just think his monologue
first off like it wasn't the funniest
monologue in all of SNL history it's
just that he came close to a subject
that makes them uncomfortable yeah
and then everyone lined up exactly like
you thought they would like the
Washington Post everyone else is like
conspiracy theorist maybe because he was
saying people were locked in their homes
in the United States I'd have never
heard of anyone being locked in there
were in China that I heard they were
being welded into their homes so locked
in yeah China was way more secure uh
Australia we're sending people to camps
where they couldn't leave their front
porch so locked in in that instance but
they're locked in Australia some
respects because you couldn't go to
school you weren't allowed to go
functionally live functionally you
couldn't or you weren't allowed to go to
Parks they filled in the sand pits at
the skate parks like you know what I
mean like they kept any they took away
anything that would be worth leaving
your house for I like how in Australia
they went to indigenous areas and
neighborhoods and and literally
kidnapped children and then brought them
to camps and then there was one viral
story where some teenagers jumped the
fence and escaped and ran for it and
they got hunted down and they got picked
up at a bar they were hanging out yeah
and I'm like these are concentration
camps and then people like Claire Lehman
of quelette were like no no it's not the
government taking people and
concentrating on one area without charge
or trial is not a concentration campus
own good stop the spread and I'm like yo
the government's rounding up indigenous
Australians and putting them in camps
and they're like but because of covet
and I'm like I didn't say not because of
covet I just said they're doing it I
think that Woody making this joke and
talking about this publicly on one of
the most popular television shows on
Earth and being one of the most popular
actors on Earth alongside with the
government's acknowledgment that it was
made in the laboratory most likely or or
you know they've concluded that it was
probably done in the lab and I think
it's all happening at once and it's
great can I just uh I want to say
something because you know I have the
Sierra Coca-Cola in a glass bottle that
I I just drank before the show and I
don't drink a lot of soda if if all if
you know ever but we do have guests who
do like so soda and so you know I don't
want to get cans and cans are okay or
bottles plastic bottles get out of here
so we got glass bottled coke with real
sugar real cane sugar and of course
everyone knows this is the famous
Mexican Coca-Cola and I was just
drinking this and I thought to myself
that's kind of crazy that in Mexico you
will get a glass bottle no no phthalates
no pcbs no endocrine disruptors made
with cane sugar no high fructose corn
syrup and it's probably cheaper in
Mexico in terms of buying power so in
terms of the Mexican economy how much
you have to work to get a Coke is
probably less work than in the United
States but in the US you're getting
plastic garbage with endocrine
disruptors and high fructose corn syrup
and that just weird like in the United
States we are poisoning and degrading
ourselves like why I don't know by
choice I mean where I I want to I think
we're the only country that mandates
fluoride in the water if I'm not
mistaken I don't know about the only
country we may be if we're not the only
it's it's very it's very few I was going
to say this earlier too just to give
people some perspective uh in two no
everybody everybody does it are you sure
yeah I thought Europe oh I know you
can't in Europe most European countries
it's not mandated a bunch of the U.N
countries yeah I think the dark red ones
are mandated mandated and then the other
ones are like I don't know I don't know
we're one of the we're one of them yeah
it's mandated what was that South
American country it doesn't explain what
the different shades mean but what is
that country which one where South
America this yeah that looks like is
that Venezuela is that Colombia or I
think it's Colombia is it uh Bolivian
I'm so that's so sad that I don't know
that I think Colombia and Bolivia are in
the middle but let's just check
just for perspective so people
understand in 2022 the pharmaceutical
industry spent 284 million dollars on
lobbying right so to give some
comparison uh our Maya on the anti-gun
side of the table always talk about how
much money that the gun lobby spends uh
it was less than 14 million
so 280 something million pharmaceutical
industry versus less than 14. maybe a
year maybe we need to get it so that you
get your the vaccines are delivered by
uh gunshot
[Laughter]
dudes less lethal uh plastic and it'll
be like a pepper ball of some sort it
wasn't that that was X-Men right was it
oh yeah it was a cure
yeah maybe thank you maybe that's the
Roundup way you do it you have uh the
Republicans pass a law saying that
vaccines can all be deliver delivered by
by a dart of some sort fired from a gun
then then they get the pharmaceutical
Lobby being like don't ban guns don't
don't ban them we love those they're
necessary yeah someone but then they're
gonna be like you you pull them to a
7-Eleven parking lot the doctor goes
don't move
hit you in the arm and you're like oh I
feel great doc you know oh what are you
saying there you go I haven't been
taking the people keep sending me these
stories about uh graphene being in the
vaccines and that people are being
trapped there's actually a patent where
they want to track People based on their
graphene and their bloodstream or
something and I just keep dismissing it
because it sounds so ridiculous but I I
just received like three messages about
it over the weekend I want to pull it up
I really do not believe there's Graphics
no there is there's graphene vaccine the
who did um died suddenly they did a
whole report on this I can send you a
link if you want but like to what extent
and what's the point of it what does it
do that is beyond my graphene knowledge
I'm going to send the report to Ian and
he'll let us all know if that's true
then I gotta I got a question Ian's
loyalty CI who are you working for him
but the thing about materials is
a plan like the nuclear bomb the nuclear
program was so amazing because it ended
up winning us the War World War II but
uh also so devastating because it gave
people access to nuclear weapons same
with graphene it's a duality to
everything yeah it'll be remaking roads
buildings rails all that but people be
making new weapons with it tracking yeah
I mean that's that's the history of the
fight I mean the reason that we have
such a robust uh defense in particular
Firearms industry here in this country
is because we won the Revolution and now
all of a sudden we're on our own uh you
know the French were our allies only
insofar as uh they want to but now they
see us as a young you know potentially
vulnerable Nation we were buying all of
our weapons from uh our allies or what
we took over with us from Britain and so
we basically had to recreate our own uh
weapons manufacturing I mean this is of
course back in the day when everything
was made by by hand right I mean Lock
Stock and Barrel that was the the old
saying so
um the corporate press says that's why
that's why that's why it's such a big
industry here people don't really
understand you know they think uh how
did that culture develop here in the U.S
but it was because we had to create it
literally from scratch to be able to
defend ourselves the corporate press
says no no graphene and oxide in the
vaccines I wonder if what people are
confusing is that they used graphene
access oxide in the manufacturing
process that is not in the vaccine
because uh some of the things I'm seeing
are people talking about fetal cells in
the vaccine fetal cells are used in the
development of these in like testing and
and production but the final product
doesn't contain the cells themselves I'm
not like actually if that's an argument
what we saw a lot of was people saying
they didn't want to take it because they
used fetal cells to make the vaccine and
then the meat was like no there's no
fetal cells in the vaccine well hold on
that's not what people were saying they
were saying that to make the product to
invent it to test it you used fetal
cells you know so we're not okay with
that with it's like you know it's like
we in order to test this we injected a
bunch of monkeys those monkeys died but
don't worry these vaccines contain no
monkey and it's like that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying you killed monkeys to
do it so I don't know to what extent
people are talking about graphene oxide
but I think it was maybe in like the
manufacturing process I guess a lot of
times that's a big problem with the food
industry is they'll show you the
ingredients the food but they don't show
you what chemicals were used in the
treatment of the Machinery before the
food is processed a lot of times yeah
and sometimes you have toxic chemicals
used to clean metal or something and how
do you completely get that off
especially for like food manufacturing
right you don't I don't think you really
can you have residue you know Justin you
were talking about the weapons
manufacturers in the United States I'm
wondering from your perspective as a
weapons manufacturing company or a head
CEO you're the executive like what do
you what are your thoughts on the
military-industrial complex and I'll
just because lately I used to think I
didn't know anything about them then 20
2007 I was like they're the they're the
villains now I'm like wait we have the
military industrial complex in the
United States if it was in another
country we'd be living in the service
would it be we would be their customer I
mean so yeah how do you do you find them
as like an evil Unstoppable force or
what do you think about this well I mean
I think
they've become that in many ways it I
mean it's it's a it's a profit
generating industry and so
um
in in today's society where it's easy
for them to say well we can just start
another war and that will be our
development ground for where we make
advancements and we test things I mean
that's that's where we are today but
that's not where it was when we began
right I mean like I said we we developed
uh this industry in the us because we
had to we had to be able to make our own
guns to defend a young uh you know up
and coming country and so
as it's developed over time and we've
like you know post World War II
obviously the rest of the world is
mostly in shambles uh we're we're
running strong
um we were really the only country left
that could produce uh much of anything
so we we basically became the supplier
to the rest of the world for uh Advanced
uh weaponry
so
as power has become concentrated in
those Industries I mean the the military
industrial complex is is a real thing
and and you know we're it's that's way
over my purview in the sense that
um you know we were very detached from
that you know they're they're they're
much larger than us
um it's it's something that I I can't
even fathom you know these are people
that are connected with politicians and
they're making back room deals and
they're writing the legislation they're
deciding where we're going to fight the
next War
um all of those things so it I think
it's an unfortunate product of
of reality you know when you have an
industry that makes money off of the
development of weapons technology
eventually somewhere along the line
um you know like the development of the
nuclear bomb so somebody looks at the
atom and says oh we could make a bomb
with this
and if that's the guy that gets all the
money and all the funding then we're
going to make a bunch of bombs and so in
the military-industrial complex uh you
have some guy in there at one point that
says hey we could actually make a lot of
money if we just started our own Wars
right instead of waiting for the next
War to happen and then figuring out how
to which side we're going to supply I
mean I think that's probably going on
forever it's like uh people have been
supplying both sides of every conflict
going back uh have you seen Sherlock
Holmes Game of Shadows the movie plot is
basically spoiler alert for this you
know 15 year old movie or whatever uh
Moriarty is he owns portions of all
these different companies and
manufacturers in different countries and
he wants a World War to start so that he
can be the financier and have debt in
all of these different places and own
everything and like I guess the premise
of the film is the industrialization of
war and they like the first machine
pistol and he's like whoa I was like
what is this they're all shocked by it
and then at the and Moriarty's like War
and the world on the industrial level is
coming you can't stop it yeah well and
naturally technology typically has
something that eclipses it and that
business dies away but with the War
Industry they just continue to up the
ante and if you give them a chance to
test it weapons yeah and and then we
tell other countries well you can't
develop your own you know like a
what whichever side you are on you know
so Iran is trying to build a nuclear
weapon and we've decided that we can't
allow that to happen and so not only do
we have these large companies here in
the U.S that are making all the weapons
but they're actively lobbying along with
politicians to not allow that kind of
weapons technology to be developed
anywhere else
yeah I mean of course it's going to be
concentrated here because we won't allow
we won't allow that industry to grow in
I mean imagine if
um
you know a pick a country pick a country
that we don't really like you know we're
going to do everything that we can
within our power I mean we really can't
tell China what to do but uh some
country that we can actually exert
influence over we're going to do
everything that we can to prevent them
from growing a weapons industry because
we don't want that to impact the
companies that we've got here yeah which
are five five of the six largest are
American the sixth is British and that
sorts I look at it as a monopoly for
sure and you might laugh and be like duh
but like literally what they've done is
they've broken it into six companies
that are technically different companies
but they're all American British
manufacturing there's Raytheon uh
Lockheed Martin's the number one then
it's Boeing Raytheon Bae is the as the
British one then there's Northrop
Grumman and General Dynamics what does
BAE stand for b-a-e systems the company
I don't know what the I don't know what
somebody's initials were off the top of
my head we'll find out Halliburton where
you said Halliburton halliburton's not
in the top leading weapons is not really
a a weapons they're more of a of a
general contractor they they just uh
yeah the nation build exactly beyond
that is Airbus which is trans European
now we're starting to look at the
non-non-british American Alliance was
there's thales in France it's only worth
nine billion the American British ones
are like 20 billion and up so they cost
you 140 billion probably like 90 95
percent of the weapons manufacturers on
Earth something like that are American
British then you get to Leonardo which
is Italian at 8.8 billion and Alma's
anti and Russian 8.5 billion that's the
first Russian manufacturing so yeah I
think that there is a monopoly on
weapons manufacturing controlled by the
British Empire American uh industry
being the weaponization arm of the
British Empire it's concerning I don't
know any way around it I don't even know
if it's the worst case scenario I mean
it's better than the Chinese I I I'm not
a war Monger but I understand the value
of War and the necessity of it at times
so yeah and obviously those companies
have developed a lot of this technology
that have civilian uses and civilians
and some of those things started off
maybe with uh like a lot of the things
that came out of DARPA have had you know
anything having to do with lasers for
example lasers have a lot of scientific
uh research uses they also have uh use
for offensive Weaponry there's just no
way around that you know the internet
um all of these things are a lot of them
are products of of weapons development
and and DARPA and the government
investing in things and you have some
aspect that's going to be useful for
civilian purposes and then you're going
to have some aspect that's going to be
useful for military purposes roads
that's another example the Roman
roadways was like the greatest military
breakthrough way to move troops exactly
yeah how did you start
your good story already
um kind of happenstance to be honest
with you so uh this was in 2015 I was
working for an insurance company and it
was an insurance company that
specialized in dealing with
manufacturers so everybody I dealt with
around the Detroit area was in the
manufacturing business of some kind a
small tool and die shops all the way up
to Big Plastics manufacturing companies
uh with you know 200 employees that was
kind of our niche market and so I I was
looking to get out of that industry and
I I had developed an affinity for what
they did I saw these guys that you know
they were building whatever widgets
parts and on the worst day of their
lives you know they their wife could be
divorcing them they they could be having
the the crappiest day possible but they
could look at the product that they made
and be satisfied that they put their
craftsmanship into it yeah and so I I
was jealous of them in that way because
you know I'm selling it it's something
tangible at the end of the day you know
it's a book full of paper that you hope
you never have to open because that's
the worst day of your life probably you
know so um my younger brother
was working for a small ammunition
reloading company at the time and you
know this was like the tail end of the
Obama presidency so this was post Sandy
Hook uh there was a big boom in in the
Firearms industry as a result you know
there was a lot of Regulation that
people were afraid of the cost of
ammunition was really high because the
demand was very high and again at the
same at that time the whole ammo
industry was controlled by a small group
of companies you know Winchester
Remington Federal these these big
players so you had a lot of small
companies starting to get into the
business of making ammo because they saw
a market for it and so uh the guy who
owned the company that he worked for
passed away and it was like a side
business he was like a rich guy had a
couple of other businesses so uh my
brother called me and said hey I think
we can buy this equipment for not that
much money I know you're thinking about
wanting to do something else what do you
think about this and so I thought about
it for a while we bought the equipment
and I I wrote a you know it was in April
of 2015 so my background is finance and
and that type of thing so I wrote a
business plan and we put the pieces
together I tried to find some Venture
Capital some money to fund it you know
struck out on that and basically decided
I was going to cash in my retirement
plan and kind of go all in so we got up
and running right before the 2016
election or you know 2015 2016 election
did you do that like did you want to be
ahead of an election year does that
influence gun sales or Amazon well it
was sort of happenstance
that it that we got everything lined up
before the election so we had a couple
of months where it was a good run-up
because you know everybody knew Hillary
Hillary was going to win yeah and so the
whole gun industry was kind of freaking
out she's gonna ban everything
um I knew a lot of people who bought
their first gun because they were afraid
Hillary Clinton yeah I mean and I I was
a consumer in the gun industry post
Sandy Hook so I was doing that I I you
know I bought a 200 uh AR-15 lower
receiver like a bunch of other people
you know does that is that what
determines commercial gun sales in
America like put pending regulations or
pending political turmoil I say that one
more time is that what sort of dictates
like if people are going to suddenly buy
a lot of guns it's not like they're like
oh it's Christmas time we're gonna uh
buy everyone a gun okay Abby I mean it
is seasonal as well people buy stuff
around the holidays uh for sure it's
kind of a winter sport here in the
Midwest as well people shoot mostly at
indoor shooting ranges and so it tends
to be a bit seasonal but yeah I mean it
it definitely tracks with the political
cycle it it it does for sure so we uh we
got up and running and then the
obviously obviously the election didn't
go the way that people thought and so
there was a bit of a struggle for the
first couple years while we tried to
figure out
um you know the demand is is dropping so
you just you can't just be the guy with
the ammo that people are going to buy at
any price you have to find a niche and
so that got us into competitive shooting
in particular people that uh do training
classes that are big consumers high
volume consumers are willing to pay a
little bit more for a premium product so
it was actually great for us in that
sense I mean if if if Hillary would have
won and
um we would have been able to just sell
whatever because people would buy
whatever we wouldn't have been able to
develop the brand the way that we have
and and uh so I'm kind of thankful for
that I would say in retrospect thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time